this program is brought to you by Emory
University
it has been quite a lot of progress or
so in terms of access to antiretroviral
treatment even in Russells limited
countries we estimate two days that
thirty-six percent of patients that need
to be an antiretroviral treatment in
Russells limited country are on
treatment today but as you know it has
been a lot of progress regarding the
development of generic and we have to my
knowledge more than 10 generic drug
available for resource limited country
today we are a little bit worried about
the future because it has been agreement
in the past between the samus ethical
companies and also with the producers of
generic like in India for example or in
Brazil and today there is new discussion
negotiation regarding the possibility to
have access to generate to to to the
developing countries so of course this
is of concern for the future
you
the preceding program is
Emory University